the machine seems to always want war
right and there's certain people that
always suck up to the machine and in
that specific case I was talking about
Stephen Colbert so anyway watch what I'm
going to do here that wasn't a total
non-sequitur Elon Musk puts out this I
it was just an idea he's just polling
people does this sound roughly like an
idea for peace well here is machine
comedian corporate comedian Stephen
Colbert going off on Elon for asking
whether we could have peace yesterday
Elon floated an insane new plan to end
the war in the most Elon Musk way
possible via Twitter poll
so what was in musk's plan redo
elections of annexed regions under U.N
supervision Crimea formally part of
Russia water supply to Crimea assured
Ukraine remains neutral so Russia gets
everything they want but in exchange
Ukraine gives Russia everything they
want
sounds like the kind of plan the Kremlin
would thank him for which could be why
shortly after the Kremlin thanked him
for it
really seems like musk is doing Russia's
bidding here explains why his latest
model Tesla is potato
top Ukrainian officials clapped back at
musk's pole Ukraine's ambassador to
Germany responded off is my very
diplomatic reply to you
that's not right the Diplomatic reply
would be please off
but you see there he's a perfect stooge
for the machine right first up he
misrepresents Elon musk's musk's
position it's not that Russia gets
everything they want he's saying if they
addict some of these places and the
people there want the annexation meaning
to go back into Russia and if Crimea is
once again part of Russia
would this be okay so that we don't end
up in a nuclear war he's not saying it
was necessarily the best thing and also
he was just floating an idea but machine
corporate comedian Stephen Colbert
basically wants you to think that Elon
Musk is a Russian stooge because he's
trying to figure out an off-ramp for
nuclear war again
Putin's got nukes and the guy when he's
losing what happens to an animal when
it's Kate when it's cornered right it's
wounded and it's cornered it can only
lash out so Putin needs an off-ramp here
you may absolutely hate Putin you may
think he's the worst dude ever you may
might hate Russia all of these things
could all be very legit you could think
he's a bully and he has no right to any
of that land or any of that stuff but
then there's also reality which is just
oh he's still got massive World altering
weapons